hi guys I wanted to show you a game
called little inferno I found it
actually on a bundle sale I saw it
awhile ago and I thought it was pretty
cool about fire and she's got some cool
cartooning people and as an indie game
just looks like my opportunity I love
all the kind of compared sport me just
hold anyways big [ __ ] poop ah I got a
message thank you
ah
thank you my heart
this sassy
go with terms and conditions am I just
bragging the chance and conditions okay
oops so didn't want you anyways so
pretty wisely pointed this goodness have
you already branch of things
you can always buy more with your brand
new catalog love miss fancy go all the
time what do you want holiday poster
corn cob on this so that's my laugh is
funny oh is it fasala tree danica okay
come look up what this tea oh my golf
ball and I'm so stupid i should not even
think about that yummy yummy yummy yummy
popcorn yummy hey it's a spider no
poster this is pretty boring dude
this is actually really fun to certain
things are like okay was it hey hey so I
don't know okay lam Kok turn it on I
can't touch it it's on fire okay it's my
monster right so you have another let
block reactors better look for the car
or plank sleepy I don't buy that matter
okay carton box
poop hey now
feels important this game is lit she
she's just Brad things it's pretty fun I
enjoy this okay ransom or somebody's ah
yeah who's this guy's now I want to see
the guy okay what's that what's that
awesome okok oh you turn so great what's
up Ari your little friends not like
other games there are no points there is
no score you're not being tight to make
a nice fire and stay warm in the glow of
your high definition entertainment
product that's why I was good but you
can't do that forever that is bound
stay warm is Nancy I love it I love it
Circle Clank right let's all over this
sleeping idol what garlic oh no that's
suited Spider okay I feel bad ah
once we've plank from a dead Matty bula
here same thing
hello and anybody the air don't know me
but i thought i would tell you it's so
cold outside i'm all snuggled up in
front of my little infernum and timid
Atlas it's so toasty I can stay here
forever like a hug and a bug in a mug I
mean a bump in a month and a bug Oh
sugar plums cause I half ah thank you
sugar plums I'm just gonna burn your
further now nice and slowly tenderly I
hope you get some marshmallows Oh Scott
it very much I woke me from yet
batteries
and also and tiki torch identity fresco
definitely a pirate oh ok sorry got too
excited ok but that trees now you are
sooo boring now hi mera to the pool I
just put it in this open fire away wow
that's pretty fun voila masterpiece mas
mother
yea big five
whoa go back oh it's me again smells
like something Vanek did you get my own
place if it's fair enough are pissed too
seems like everyone has fun these days
everyone I know has fun and then one I
don't know has one to do burning stuff
is pretty fun be careful instructor said
there's something even more dangerous
fire but I brand them so we'll never
know I've been to a new new friend sugar
plums right Twix bar to tell you someone
else's family portrait possibly yes to
see this is obscure ler jar of fireflies
van stuff okay okay you swore
assassinated shipped packaged to make it
arrived in to thee just click on the
ship oh ok I got a message it's me good
haha thought you actually start to ok
annoying I already brand on my staff we
send something no I need some more
fireflies
portrait that's my jar for advice this
is my seat pocket oh cool that's not
possible but it well haha lovely okay so
I some fireflies cuz she took our sugar
plum my pictures you can find the
pictures but you can't find a memory
very very true oh my pitches get me for
Burnley and for sugar for 100
spider i ah I want you to kill someone
it we're like okay what's this totally
forgot Oh someone else's number all
right okay right where the fireflies so
pretty I put down nicely sleep yeah and
now I'm very sorry
oh oh oh it's me my okay haha baby burn
just go oh sorry me baby baby oh ok and
then oh yes you come just in time writer
oh my gosh creepy I was so freaked out
of this is real life burn out of spiders
ah ah thank you for my new 5 life each
one was like a little wish to see where
they go but they all burned out well sir
we knew they would last forever oh I got
you something okay it's attached just
clip over the narrow flip it look again
okay here it is it's free paper heart
I'm gonna burn this paper heart put all
the threads spiders pieces on it I want
to clear up the dust I wish we could
have a broom okay what little inferno is
still the secret and I just found one
don't worry I won't tell you that would
be a spoiler but it's really good okay
I'm just going to draw something alarm
clock blast + + + flower equals
love and tell you to definitely do not
burn those two things together ha and
there are more more combinations that
can ever be listed love sugar pie this
one
Oh celebration bus zoom zoom where's it
go I wanted the bus driver I know ah ok
I thought we leave these magical appear
like on screen I cool like through the
hearts 11 credit card i divide the money
crystal now I need first amitabh us if I
could've acted like a dbag giving our
paternal ladies
ah just perfect ok bus we're just bus go
nobody knows except the drive um excuse
me oh wow that was cool let's get house
alone TV you can change the job is only
one thing on TV Oh is so cool it's the
game just fill it up steam isn't fun ah
it's just a simple I knew I'd enjoy this
working whatever part it's gonna be
another call from folks snows be coming
down flat
MD colon alas that can last forever hey
build a nice cozy fire stay warm cell
phones yeah is he like controlling the
weather recording from the mother
other folks that
so dramatic I love it okay what other
concoctions we come up with generations
leaders movie night okay okay
oh I just know is I'm so stupid ok ok
I'm passionate so cuddly ah yeah how's
it screw up whistle oh yes oh the turret
our way there is courage the cowardly
dog can put a resume eat your bunny
plushie let's get to the heart of the
top ok oh so cute though ah it sounds
like a real one this is very good ok
oh you've already found my second
catalog did you know your head with
fredo comes the free instructional video
Oh Nancy oh cool hey kids do you like
toys oh you know what's more fun than
playing with toys setting them on fire
with your new little inferno
entertainment fire please
me
when I start playing with fire with
danger well you're right but up out of
your chimney way up in the sky it's been
snowing for years and we just don't know
why our world is getting colder but
there's no need for alarm just sit by
your fire burn all of your toys and stay
warm
I
it's a
wow that was different okay well I'm
gonna do with that if you want to see
any more little Inferno then yeah let me
know will burn some more stuff we'll
have some fun give me a thumbs up if you
like this I'm really appreciate it and
you silly i have a lovely day or evening
bye
ah